el Hoya Busca evitar una catástrofe
mundial director general del alto
organismo para la energía nuclear de la
ONU finalizó su tan esperada visita a la
planta de purilla donde antes de partir
expresó su preocupación y dijo que cinco
de los comisionados se quedarán por lo
menos hasta el próximo sábado
no vamos a ninguna parte eloidea ahora
está allí está en la planta y no se
moverá se quedará allí vamos a tener una
presencia continua en la planta con
algunos de mis expertos Y por supuesto
que ahora tenemos más trabajo en
términos de un análisis detallado de
algunos aspectos más técnicos los cuales
vinimos a revisar análisis
[Música]
este jueves antes de la llegada de los
14 miembros del equipo de inspección de
la ONU al menos tres personas murieron
durante una jornada de ataques por parte
de la artillería ucraniana la
instalación nuclear más grande de Europa
ha sido ocupada por las fuerzas rusas
pero está dirigida por ingeniero
sucranianos Desde los primeros días de
la guerra Hace seis meses entre las
acusaciones por parte y parte de
intentar sabotear la visita de la Hoya
energuatón empresa encargada del manejo
de la planta decidió Desactivar uno de
los reactores entre tanto esperan que la
situación se calme para que pronto se
pueda reactivar
creemos que el objetivo principal de
esta Misión del oea es desmilitarizar el
territorio de la planta de energía
nuclear de zaporiya y el área
circundante Si esta misión ayuda a hacer
Esto entonces era un éxito
la planta de zaporilla se encuentra
ubicada al sur de un enorme embalse en
el río nipro el cual es tomado como un
punto una persona gris que divide los
combates entre las fuerzas rusas y las
ucranianas